this is the most exciting thing I've
ever seen with a toilet roll what's the
best way to get over the fear of flying
well for New Yorker mark Malkoff it was
living on a plane for a record-breaking
thirty days but what pleased our experts
was that he used the time to answer the
oldest question in aviation how powerful
is the flush and a plane's toilets
I put the toilet paper one end in the
toilet and then roll the entire roll in
the aisle of the airplane and then I
press flush and supposedly it will suck
the entire roll into the toilet let's
see if it works
impressive but what's behind this
toilets potent vacuum the airplane is
incapable of carrying the weight of
water needed to flush in a conventional
sense
everybody everybody product in the
toilet right so they have to completely
redesign the flush and they do this with
a vacuum flush the pressure outside is
very very low the pressure inside
relatively is a lot higher by a clever
system of valves and tanks they're able
to tap off some of this pressure so you
have this tank which is extremely low
pressure and then the relatively high
pressure of the toilet by pressing a
button and opening this other valve mark
and his vanishing toilet roll
demonstrated beautifully our change in
air pressure creates a vacuum